all right
[Music]
so i have to mention that before this
first read-through i made note of a few
key components such as the time
signature which alternates between 6 8
and 9 8. the key signature which for now
has no sharps or flats
and the general contour of the material
in the form of chords and lines that i
visualize in this way
or maybe this
also anything that catches my eye for
example rhythmic characteristics
the range
the melody and the general variety of
notes
[Music]
okay
so then i continued reading for the rest
of the page
and now that we've got our first
impressions out of the way i'm going to
move on to working on the hands
separately
the way i would organize my fingers for
this would be
descending fifths
and then another descending fifths
that's a lot easier than thinking about
these groups of three
[Music]
basically it's the difference between
seeing these notes as a pair of
descending fifths or this
interesting here
so the 9 8 measure here
[Music]
that is a little awkward
that fourth interval we're not really
used to playing that
in this context so instead
[Music]
for fingering i might choose to
[Music]
play the d here with my fifth finger
and then switch hand positions
completely so that i'm playing the g
with my third finger
and then i'm holding this position
[Music]
so i'm switching from
this position to this one
so my intention here is to find
fingerings that correspond to simplified
hand positions
i'm not sure
i'm going to keep tabs on this
okay so that middle section is the
trickiest part
so i've made up my mind i'm sticking
with the five to three jump
[Music]
here i'm beginning to mark up the score
and now i'm making note of the fact that
the right hand chords are all major
triads in this section
[Music]
alright one of the most important things
for this section i think is to
sectionalize it so here are the groups
that i see for now
so basically i divided the page into
sections that group similar material
together in terms of repeated phrases
patterns and or harmony now that i'm
more organized i have a better sense of
structure when it comes to the different
parts that i'll focus in on
[Music]
what i notice is that
all of these are centered around
f sharp and c
so
it's just climbing up by tritones
[Music]
so just simplifying that helps
decode what's going on
physically
[Applause]
[Music]
the left hand i'm going to divide into
three sections
[Music]
so arguably here from f
it's all the same scale but i'm breaking
it up into two because
of the thumb placement
so it's sort of a pianist way of
organizing things i think
so next i'll practice this in a few
different ways
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
as you can see this type of run-through
is still a waste of time at this point
and also the other section didn't really
stick but this is pretty normal it'll
take a lot more runs for there to be
consistency and execution
now i'm taking small groups of notes and
chords that are awkward for me to play
and i'm adding some notes around them so
i can repeat them in ways that are
slightly less mundane than just
repeating them in isolation
here's where i looked up a recording of
it i'm listening to martha argerich
[Music]
what
huh okay
[Applause]
so the fact that i proceeded to try
playing it at a faster tempo than before
is
pretty funny
but i also think it's good to be aware
of one's limitations
[Applause]
[Music]
so at this point the wise thing to do
would probably be to continue to
practice in small groups carefully
analyze the tricky spots in order to
find
better solutions around them
and slowly build up tempo
why is that harder after the break but
in reality i tried to use brute force to
get the passage down
but it's still interesting to see how
ineffective a lot of the work i was
doing in this context was
[Music]
if you haven't already seen it i
recently did a video with david bruce
and three other composers where all of
us use the same material to write a
piece for a unique chamber ensemble the
video goes really in depth about the
behind the scenes process of music
composition plus i'm a fan of all of the
composer's works so i'd highly recommend
checking it out also i'd like to
announce that i've created a patreon so
thank you so much in advance for your
support in helping me continue to work
on music and these videos
thank you for watching and i'll see you
in the next video